[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина]
Люди не бачили іншого життя.
[Слов'янськ
Платформа  «Теплиця»]
Вони їздили на заробітки до Росії.
[Ганна Авдіянц
Співзасновниця платформи ініціатив «Теплиця»]
Така була можливість створити «Теплицю»,
і в нас була мета —
показати людям інше життя.
Звичайно, краще і легше
працювати з  молоддю.
Показувати їм, яке життя за межами
Донецької і Харківської областей.
Ми показуємо, що є Україна інша,
і що в ній набагато краще жити,
ніж в ДНР, що за 100 кілометрів звідси,
ніж тим життям,
яке було в нас декілька місяців тут.
Незрозумілі люди сюди приїхали
і почали встановлювати свій порядок.
[Краматорськ
Простір «Вільна Хата»]
Потім тут перекривають дороги,
будують блокпости якісь.
Це ж ненормально.
Я народився в Україні,
я хочу жити в Україні,
а не в якійсь там міфічній республіці,
яку придумали кілька людей.
Все це почалось у 2014 році
з волонтерського табору
«Будуймо Україну разом».
Тут були волонтери з Краматорська
і зі всієї України.
Ми ремонтували помешкання,
які постраждали внаслідок бойових дій.
Ну і якось так сформувалась спільнота,
яка хотіла робити щось далі.
Зокрема, відбудовувати не тільки
помешкання, але і суспільство.
Тому, що ми вже бачили,
до чого призвела бездіяльність
або байдужість.
Не хочеться,
щоб це повторювалось і поверталось.
Потім до нас приїжджали
активісти зі Слов'янська,
з'явилась «Теплиця».
Потім з'явився вільний простір
«Майстерня» у Бахмуті.
Ще до цього — у Дружківці,
в Костянтинівці, в Лимані...
[Костянтинівка
Простір «Druzi»]
І так якось воно розросталось
по Донецькій області
і в двох містах Луганської області.
[Простір «Дружба»
Лисичанськ]
Люди почали об'єднуватись
і щось робити спільно.
Ми зрозуміли, що якщо нічого не робити,
то хтось зробить за нас.
[Юрій Соколов
Член наглядової ради «Теплиці»]
Потреба була — знайшлись люди,
зустрілись і почали робити.
Юрко займається розвитком
неформальної освіти
і організовував зустрічі
з успішними людьми.
Сашко займається розвитком
культурного напрямку.
Дар'я займається соціальним напрямком,
розвиває в нашому місті інклюзивність
і займається з дітьми з інвалідністю,
а також розвитком волонтерства.
[Слов'янськ
Коворкінг «Top Place»]
Це простір «Top Place»,
спрямований на розвиток
соціального підприємництва в східному регіоні
та, зокрема, в Слов'янську.
[Гання Каліта
Співзасновниця «Top Place»]
Зараз ми знаходимося в нашому івент-просторі.
Також він перетворюється
на простір для курсів та тренінгів.
Там у нас є кімната для переговорів
і маленька кухня для коворкерів,
які приходять до нас працювати.
Також робимо освітні курси
з сучасних професій для містян
щоб вони мали можливість
розвивати свою підприємницьку діяльність,
або працювати на фрилансі на великі міста
і бути конкурентноспроможними тут.
І залишатися в східному регіоні —
не виїжджати звідси.
Якщо ми всі поїдемо,
то нічого не залишиться гарного.
Зараз є нагальна потреба в тому,
щоб молодь знала,
як здобувати додаткову освіту.
Тому що, на жаль,
система загальної освіти
не відповідає сучасним вимогам.
Тому ми показуємо, як і де шукати
джерела для додаткової освіти.
Вчимо молодь, як можна
навіть у 15 років вже заробляти.
На Сході дуже багато
міжнародних організацій працює,
завдяки яким з'явилось багато
таких платформ, як наша.
Одна річ, коли в тебе є бажання,
жага щось робити,
ти це робиш,
але це крок за кроком,
дуже довго це може розвиватися.
Донорська підтримка ж
додає динаміки
і більше можливостей
для реалізації твоїх ідей,
для розвитку твого міста
і наповнення середовища.
Тому що ми відповідальні не тільки за себе.
Якщо ти хочеш жити нормально,
то зроби щось для цього.
Ти можеш завжди кудись тікати, їздити,
але рано чи пізно
ти повертаєшся додому.
Повертатися в якесь таке
сумне місце не хотілося б.
Я приїхала до рідні в Харків
І коли ми поїхали на пляж...
[Дар'я Ніколаєнко
Співзасновниця простору «Теплиця»]
Я телефон залишила в машині.
Багато друзів було, які теж повиїжджали.
І я приходжу в машину, беру телефон,
а в мене там десять пропущених дзвінків
і повідомлення, що місто все у вогні.
А я розумію, що в мене там
мама, тато і сестра.
І я починаю дзвонити,
не можу додзвонитися.
В мене починається істерика.
Це пляж, купа людей,
ніхто не розуміє, що зі мною.
Я ридаю, ніхто не може мене зупинити.
І я розумію, що
ми просто сідаємо в машину...
Добре, що ми не відключили
домашній телефон.
Я додзвонилася
на домашній телефон.
Коли я почула просто голос батька,
я зрозуміла, наскільки цінним є те,
що ми раніше не помічали й не цінували.
Коли я сюди повернулася,
я йшла вулицею:
тут відновлювали воду,
працював один магазин.
В мене був такий шок, бо це був ніби місто-апокаліпсис з фантастичних фільмів.
І потім стало зрозуміло,
що якщо ти не будеш як людина,
як особистість рухатися вперед,
то це просто все повториться.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори Павло Пашко,
Олег Сологуб, КОстянтин Бріжніченко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]